join our weekly Amazon giftcard giveaway
all you have to do is be subscribed to
our channel like this video and leave a
comment about today's topic we will
choose winners randomly from the comment
section
the last giveaway winners are pls
private message me to claim your gift
hey guys in the season 6 finale sim
finally arrived at the second largest
and by far the oldest never-before-seen
city in the Seven Kingdoms all Town to
begin his training as a maester even
though the official trailer haven't
provided us any shot of similarly there
are a bunch of promotional photos that
are confirming that Sam will doubtlessly
continue to be a major character and
will play a huge role in the upcoming
season the main question about Sam and
his role is what exactly will send find
out during his training at the world's
largest and oldest library well there's
a high possibility of Sam finding out a
cure for Juris disease let's not forget
that Jon has sent santol town to become
maester in order to explore and find out
a way to defeat the night King and his
undead army while finding out the secret
of forging Valyrian steel that was lost
in the doom of Valyria would also be a
great accomplishment having in mind that
Sam will not even stay in the several
this entire season but will rather leave
all Tom for Winterfell sometime later
this season it's easy to assume that Sam
will find out something important
something that will be game-changing Sam
already knows pretty much everything
about the White Walkers which means that
every further information will be of the
crucial importance once the only word
that matters comes there's a promotion
photo released a few weeks ago that
contains senator Lee and Gilly clearly
studying and learning some new stuff in
Oldtown
or the most important thing about this
photo is in fact that Gil is reading
about azor Ahai Gilly reading about a
legendary hero who lived approximately
8,000 years before Aegon's landing and
defeated the others during the long
night building a sword of fire called
light bringer doesn't mean similar read
it as well according to prophecy in
ancient books of ash I from over 5,000
years ago azor Ahai is to be reborn
again to challenge the others which will
take place after long summer when an
evil cold darkness descends upon the
world while either Daenerys or Jon Snow
is the prophesized leader it most likely
will not be revealed in seventh but
rather in the final eighth season was
the night
his undead army actually invade and
conquer most of the Seven Kingdoms if
you would like to know more about azor
Ahai as well as which character might be
a hero that will stand against degree
toddler feel free to check out a video
of mine by the name who is azor Ahai
while sam is learning about history
healing and strategy at the world's
greatest library same story in season
seven would be much more interesting if
Jorah comes to seek help at all town as
it is the site of the Citadel which
would not be surprising since masters
and healers managed to cure the daughter
of Stannis Baratheon who was infected by
this same disease there's a possibility
that Samet help of an arch maester who
tests novices seeking their link in the
art of healing will discover a cure for
jurors disease and will save his life
additionally as I already mentioned in
my previous videos there's a
confirmation that jim broadbent english
actor will appear in the upcoming season
and will play his role as an arch
maester which has actually been
confirmed by an actor himself as in one
interview broadband said I'm a maester
and archmaester I'm an all professor
character while he also confirmed that
his scenes were shared with an actor
that portrays Sam with all of this being
said it's easy to assume that Jim
Broadbent will appear as ebro's an arch
maester the citadel who tests novices
seeking their link in the art of healing
there is certainly a possibility that
Sam with the help of an arch maester
will cure Juris disease if Jorah truly
comes to seek the help at the Citadel
however I still will not exclude the
possibility of qwave being Jorah Savior
cuase also known as the Quaid of the
shadow appeared in the second season in
only a few scenes which was more than
enough to realize that she has some
special capabilities the last time I've
seen Jorah he was watching the nearest
Targaryen and her new Callister living
out of this dog track whereupon he
started his new quest so the last time
I've seen her he was leaving the only
city in the track is si located near the
far north eastern edge of the region
which is far closer to Qarth a place in
majora meta with a powerful woman
Quaithe who might know how to cure his
disease far closer than old town in
which his disease might be cured by Sam
let me know your opinion regarding this
topic in the comment section down below
do you think jury will go straight to
the Seven Kingdoms and seek for help of
masters in the Citadel or do you think
jury will firstly try to find a cure in
Essos and they look for Quaithe who
seems to be his
best chance of survival since she knows
how to protect people from greyscale
which might mean that she knows how to
cure the same a few months ago I brought
you a video in which I explained how Sam
will most likely find out the secret
about jongseo parentage as well as
John's real birth name even though he
will not be the one to reveal it to him
if you're wondering how will Sam find
out the sacred debt at this moment only
two people know about or how John Snow
will find out the truth as well as what
his birth name might be make sure to
click a very on top of your screen
in conclusion beside Joshua parentage
Sam will discover at least a few secrets
that will be of the crucial importance
was the night King decides to take the
Seven Kingdoms
while there's also high possibility that
say will be the one to cure Joris
disease I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one peace